le dicton du jour à la saint parfait
quand on se refait condamné à 120 heures
de travail communautaire pour avoir
agressé un supporter l'international
français a commencé cet après midi à
s'acquitter de sa dette
apprendre le foot à de jeunes de
manchester commentaire de notre
correspondant bernard lebrun il ne
faisait pas très chaud ce matin dans le
nord de l'angleterre mais les
photographes zettel a malheureusement
terrain couvert à 14 heures le
professeur cantona est descendu de sa
limousine portant la couleur rouge de ce
qui est toujours son club manchester
united
il n'aura qu'un mot pour les
photographes non je ne suis pas là pour
vous mais pour les enfants un peu de
respect s'il vous plaît ces petits
hommes verts ce sont les premiers
heureux élus
les enfants de kanto ils ont entre 7 et
11 ans ils viennent d'à côté de l'école
délaissent leurs parcs tels des stars
ils ont été filmés hier à l'entraînement
veille du grand jour est de savoir que
l'on va rencontrer le maître
croyez-moi ça stimule car la fia d'avoir
cantona d'être entraînée par cantona
pour apprendre à mieux jouer
le professeur en tenue de travail porte
aussi la casquette
eric a fait savoir qu'il était impatient
de commencer ses 120 heures de travaux
forcés toutes les deux heures quant aux
l'éducateur change de groupe au total ce
sont 700 enfants qui passeront entre ses
mains et non pas à ses pieds d'orfèvre
de refaire du ballon rond 700 grammes de
champion qui pourront dire un jour quant
aux moi je l'aï eu comme prof deux
heures de rêve dans la vie d'un apprenti
footballeur
le professeur lui n'a rien dit en
partant et pour les autographes ce
n'était pas vraiment le jour cantona
avait l'air fatigué de ses quatre
premières heures
même si comme travaux forcés on a vu
pire en angleterre